[Música]
la casa pata arriba Dónde están las
armas
[Música]
las fuerzas armadas del Ecuador
realizamos operaciones de control de
armas municiones explosivos el día de
hoy hemos realizado una operación de
apoyo a la Policía Nacional para
proporcionarle la seguridad en algunos
allanamientos
[Música]
Dile que diga dónde están todas las
armas
[Música]
cuánto para el trabajo ahora se nos
dificulta más porque no existe la
garantías de gobierno no existe la
garantía
fuera de la policía que se puede decir
también aquí porque
las bandas la inseguridad
no nos dejan trabajar libremente
[Música]
se han cerrado porque no hay ocupación
no hay consumo por el miedo por las
extorsiones por todo este tipo de
cosas que están pasando en actualmente
en la ciudad y en la provincia de
esmeraldas
[Música]